what's the talk
let's get talking man it's bruce
okay i've got two in the reactor i got a
long one yeah yeah i got a
reactor as well okay omar come on with
you have jacob yeah
let's go i'm going through the locker
room
what is this game this is a uh it's like
a lot of like secret hitler type of okay
farley we're going
there omar did you make it a
decontamination i didn't oh
no is anyone going up to the top thing
yeah i'm doing the top one
all right i'm leaving jacob oh okay wait
no hold on
oh [ __ ] two five no more i'm still here
you and i are together right now i'm
flipping the switch bruce is done
flipping that switch hey bruce how's it
going
typing wait should i know what these
numbers are
you just have to click them in order oh
okay
it doesn't tell you to do that but i
eventually found out that's how you do
it
all right bruce let's get out of here oh
we already done i'm getting the [ __ ] out
of here
oh
wait jacob you ditched me i'm going to
the reactor i am by myself
i don't think about it i just saw a lot
of past me
all right all right well jacob died
jacob was next to me who else was
i feel like omar and i were together for
a bit and then i had to veer off i have
no knowledge of anything
i just talked about andy finally left me
with jacob and then he ditched me
and then he died i left jacob in the
decontamination room
and then moved on and i heard him cut
out
if bruce left without jacob then it's
probably omar
it's not he's the only one there no wait
wait no didn't
didn't omar say that no who did omar say
that farley
was it was jacob
jacob jacob farley left first so that i
never saw him
i was doing the thing in the reactor
jacob told me i hit the number
in order no i'm i think bruce
no i left jacob and i walked out of the
same room the decontamination room i
went right he went left
there's no left i think i'm gonna go oma
jacob taught me how to do the the task i
had in the reactor room with him
i don't think it's probably probably
bruce then if bruce
if he left with jacob i don't think it's
me guys what's the logic that it spruce
yeah i don't know sound logic because
omar jacob and i were in reactor
i left bruce went in and omar didn't see
anything but jacob's dead
so i think it's bruce kitsune had a
chance to kill me straight away and
didn't
so that means
i ran by farley i saw alana up near the
top
but i didn't see where andy you're the
only person that i was next to right
then but it's not like we were in the
same room or anything i have no [ __ ]
idea what happened
i feel like i'm going i don't know i
voted
i i voted bruce because he was the only
other person who says he was up in that
area
all right don't know [ __ ] i also by the
way by the way did not vote for omar
just so everybody's aware
you're not for omar who did you vote for
why do you think it says
that's not true why do you think it's
not me by what logic is omar we'll stay
together
omar says it's not him all right i'm
going i'm going up here
okay bruce is here already right that's
the thing it sounds like [ __ ] i'm
always alone with jacob all right go for
it
that's true i don't actually
[Music]
i'm in the office below you the officer
i'm with the sneaky tree or whatever
sneaky g i don't know who that is uh is
so is anyone going towards the reactor
yeah yeah i am currently
going forward
okay all right so my next two are in the
laboratory area
yeah that's why me too yeah okay okay
bruce was up behind us that's right look
i'm holding
careful careful yeah there's people here
he was trying to clear mine oh alana's
in here with me and i just walked by i'm
going i'm going i'm going in here
always calling out where i am okay okay
he's got a knife to your back mine's
right up here at the top oh
hey it's andy it's andy it's andy andy's
the guy and he killed partly
andy killed harley
did andy just [ __ ] kill someone in
front of you i guess yeah
eddie killed farley right in front of me
obama where are you right now we'll help
you
well and the laboratory because i'm
trying to run away from me
[Laughter]
it's andy it's absolutely andy one of
the killers he just killed
and he didn't have any defense
whatsoever i don't know i have no
defense because i thought someone was
gonna team up with me
and i'll be quiet now all right
jesus christ andy all right so omar
thank you
andy do the kill i saw andy kill farley
i saw it happen
but i think he's saying that he was
supposed to team up with alana and alana
[ __ ] him
i was literally outside yeah i have to
vote for andy right now but i think
alana is also going to vote me out dude
i'm dead as hell bro yeah
i don't actually admit it's like you
don't know about you don't guilty dude
tell me
sorry
try to just get me life in prison please
the voting countdown's too long
not because omar saw andy do it
normally we were arguing well now that
there's 20 seconds maybe it was omar
okay all right bro yeah sure why wait
yeah andy why
just cause bro
omar was like tattling on him
i usually get so like flustered by the
person being near me that i don't say
anything in time
all right well i'm voting for him i
[ __ ] hate you guys
i hate everybody omar
all right bro omar i offered you money
dog
oh let me skip sorry i'll vote for omar
[ __ ] it in a bucket dude
just because it's just fun i offered you
money dog
oh man that was so funny all right well
andy definitely had a cohort that he
thought was gonna kill me and
that didn't happen and then i think
alana was the next person in the world i
mean i was vaguely near you guys but i
was in the airlock i have no [ __ ]
idea
who else was nearby um but that is
like i don't even know what his plan
somebody's in here with me [ __ ]
somebody keeps telling me who who's the
name well no i was doing the thing i
can't see the name when the thing is up
i just see a body coming up on me
oh it's already done alana's in here
though alana's in here though hello i'm
here
you ain't got [ __ ] to worry about
[ __ ] chill out bro no
oh my gosh dude stinky jeez it's chasing
me
everybody's like panicking right now
this is very serious business oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
where'd you go i don't like this
yeah oh my god bruce all right bruce
that was a
smooth kill what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
andy i was a too far away to have any
idea what you meant
communication and b why did you say it
you guys oh first killed me of
holy [ __ ] oh my god i always say
appreciate andy's response to being
accused
you can't prove it
how many important i thought we had i
thought we had
like a a communication that was
non-verbal and it was like there's two
people in here there's no no so so i was
so i was trying one person a lot of
ghosts to the airlock i was like [ __ ]
yeah i mean i didn't know that you
killed them but when i realized that you
had i was gonna go kill emma but
he saw you so it was way too soon like
it wasn't gonna work oh yeah
omar knew every kill so like you know
just next time maybe like don't
don't out someone when you die [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we want anyway it's okay
sorry guys oh you might need to change
that i just forgot to put my i thought
i thought everybody was gonna get omar
or get uh bruce after
he got me broad daylight in the airlock
and then andy's blunder eclipsed
everything
i'm trying to oh [ __ ] mimosas andy's
trying to get a reduced sentence